Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today.
Joe Walsh, former U.S. representative from
Illinois, former presidential candidate, host
of the podcast White Flag with Joe Walsh.
Always great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: David, always good to be with you.
I'm a huge fan.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Thank you.
So okay, let's let's just jump right into
the some of the meat here.
2022, for historical reasons, should have
been great for Republicans.
Red wave predicted by some red wave that ended
with Democrats gaining a seat, although now
they kind of lost it because of Kirsten cinema.
But it seems she'll still, I guess, caucus
with Democrats.
It's still sort of shaking out.
Ronna McDaniel was recently asked on Fox News
how much of what happened was because of Donald
Trump and she said she doesn't really want
to talk about that.
To what degree do you think what happened
is because of Donald Trump?
Speaker 5: I think pretty much the whole thing
was because of Donald Trump.
Americans rejected all these crazy these bat,
you know what, crazy election denying candidates.
Where did all these election denying crazy
anti democracy candidates come from?
Trump Trump pushed them.
They came from his stable.
They are him.
And I give David, I give Biden a lot of credit
because he stuck to this defending democracy
thing when a lot of smart Democratic advisers
said, come on, President Biden, move off of
that, focus on inflation and gas.
But he stuck with it.
I think of a lot of a lot of Americans generally
said we do want to defend democracy.
Speaker 1: They're assuming that that's true.
And again, when you look at split tickets,
like when you look at Georgia, for example,
and you see Brian Kemp easily won and then
Herschel Walker lost, I mean, not by much,
but he did lose.
But the gap between Walker and Kemp was significant.
It does suggest that Republican voters were
discerning in terms of which Republicans they
were willing to vote for.
Once we look at that.
We have a new poll that finds almost two thirds
of Republicans, even if they like Trump policy,
they don't want him to be the nominee in 2024.
There are increasingly analyzes that say Trump
won't even make it to the first primaries.
Is What do you think?
Speaker 5: I'd say I'd say two things, David.
He's the king of this party.
He right now remains the cult leader.
My former party is a cult, so do not write
him off at all.
But what I will say is this I'm in a weird
spot, right?
Because I come from a mega cult.
I still engage with the mega cult every day.
And I will say two things about Republican
base voters that I talk to every day.
They all want Trump ism.
They all want that.
And we all know what that is.
And increasingly, they're concerned and worried
that maybe Trump is no longer the voice of
that.
Not.
Here's the important point, David, that, you
know, not because they think there's anything
wrong with Trump.
They just don't think he can win.
So will this be permanent?
I don't know.
And I don't.
The other thing I'd say, David, is who's going
to slay the king?
Who's going to slam?
Speaker 1: Well, I mean, it is interesting
that DeSantis, without having even announced
in some polls, is easily beating a former
president of the United States that it's a
signal that maybe DeSantis can do it.
But, you know, when I think about imagine,
DeSantis says, I'm running and a national
campaign starts.
You know, I don't know.
I mean, can DeSantis actually handle that?
I'm not sure.
Speaker 5: I know DeSantis.
I know him pretty well in in the pre-Trump
days.
Look, he's got zero charisma.
He's not good on his feet.
Yeah, he's very thin skinned.
And most Republicans around the country really
don't know who he is.
He is a marker right now.
He's a default spot for all of these Trump
voters who want Trump ism and they don't know
where else to go.
I tend to believe that once he's under a national
spotlight, I don't think he'll do well.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Yeah.
And I've read a number of pieces that say
brilliant guy, much more competent than Trump,
but sort of like constitutionally, he may
not really have what it takes to actually
face the national campaign with the nicknames
and the debt.
But but at the same time, it is a different
Trump.
I mean, if you just look at Trump's something,
I don't know what's going on with Trump, but
when you look at video from six years ago
from from 2015, 2016, his facility with language
and the insults and the quips and whatever,
he does seem diminished at this point to some
degree.
Would you agree?
Speaker 5: I don't know.
But what I do know, David, is where is he
been?
I get that he had to announce a month ago
because if he didn't announce, he'd look like
a loser.
So he had to come out.
Yeah.
Thinking that the midterms would be a big
victory for him.
But I got to tell you something, David.
Every single day I hear Republican voters
tell me every day, Hey, Joe, shut up.
Twitter did steal the 2020 election.
I told you it was rigged.
Now, this is a huge issue, an animating issue
for Republican voters.
It's a it's a lay up for Trump.
And I don't know why Donald Trump has not
been more active.
I don't know why he's not on Twitter.
I don't know why he's not holding a rally
somewhere right now screaming that Twitter
stole the 2020 election.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's it's strange a report
I don't remember if it was Vanity Fair.
Which one?
That Trump has barely left his house since
making the announcement.
He did an interview with Oann yesterday where
he's mentioning, I guess, some rallies that
maybe are planned.
But it's I don't know how much momentum is
going to be behind those at this point.
Is there still a standard bearer right now
in the Republican Party that is the more kind
of prototypical conservative constitutionalist,
small government, Republican, like is it is
it like Mitt Romney?
Maybe.
Is there anyone left right now?
Speaker 5: No.
Huh.
David, there's no standard bearer for that
wing of the party because I don't believe
that wing of the party is a real wing anymore.
The standard the standard bearer for the party
is still Trump until somebody knocks him down.
And here's here's what I think about all the
time.
David, I left the party two and a half years
ago, yet one of Trump's most outspoken critics,
I'm still a crazy Tea Party conservative.
If I ran in a Republican primary next year,
I wouldn't have a shot because I opposed Trump.
Liz Cheney could never win in this party.
Adam Kinzinger could never win.
So if not Trump, the party is either you love
Donald Trump or you'll be just like in better
than Trump.
I don't see room for any other Republican
for a while.
Speaker 1: It does seem, though, that in the
right district you would absolutely have a
shot, does it?
I mean, in a less Trumpy district, I don't
know.
Speaker 5: A Republican primary.
Speaker 1: In a Republican primary.
Well, I mean, listen, I guess it depends to
what degree the Trump MAGA Association continues
to be to diminish in importance, I guess.
I guess we don't know.
Speaker 5: I would, David, I would probably
have better luck running as a very conservative
Democrat.
Speaker 1: Maybe so.
Maybe so.
What do you expect now in the in these.
Two years because, of course, Democrats will
have the majority in the Senate depending
on what happens with Kirsten Cinema.
It'll be 5050 or it'll be 5149.
But either way, it's a majority.
To get things done that require a simple majority
probably can't get much done that require
60 votes over in the House, Republicans taking
control, clearly in interest in investigating
Hunter Biden, maybe even Hillary's emails,
maybe Whitewater.
We don't know how far back they're going to
go, what exactly is going to happen legislatively,
if anything at all?
Speaker 5: Nothing right now that for certain.
David, we know that nothing legislatively
is going to happen.
My former colleagues in the House have made
clear and they're not going to veer off of
this, that they're going to investigate every
Democrat that they can investigate and they
may try to impeach a few Democrats.
Kevin McCarthy, I still believe, will be speaker.
But David, he's sold every inch of his body.
And I know a lot of people say this.
I said this a long time ago.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE will be the speaker
in reality, really.
She'll be squeezing McCarthy so hard for two
years.
It's going to be her.
And the other thing we know these next two
years are going to be like is it's going to
be Trump craziness.
I think he's going to be indicted.
I think he may be indicted a couple of times.
And then what do Republican Party voters do?
Do they rally around him?
Do they say that's it?
I don't know.
Speaker 1: When it comes to the Hunter Biden
stuff.
I haven't heard you weigh in on it.
You know, my view has been I don't really
care about Hunter Biden in the sense that
he has nothing to do with the administration.
If he did commit some crime and you can prove
it, investigate, indict what?
I just don't care.
I know.
It's like I wasn't out there defending Anthony
Wiener, and I just I don't really care.
The problem I have is it's being used to attack
Joe Biden in a way that seems disconnected
from the facts that we have right now.
What is your sense of the of the entire Hunter
Biden situation?
Speaker 5: It's it's David.
You nailed that.
It's purely political.
I mean, I've had some Republicans tell me
privately that they have to go after Hunter
Biden because the base is demanding it.
Look, let's let's be real.
I think you and I are consistent on this.
It pisses me off to no end when people use
their service or their family's service in
government to enrich themselves.
Jared Kushner did that.
Hunter Biden did that with his dad for years.
That's not his dad.
That's him.
The Justice Department will decide what they
want to do with him.
But this is just David.
This is red meat.
Red meat for the base.
And they have to throw some of this stuff
at them for these two years.
Speaker 1: Do you think they will go as far
in the house as to actually try to impeach
Joe Biden?
Speaker 5: No, I don't.
I there are some in the caucus who want to.
But I think generally as McCarthy is trying
to become speaker, he's cutting deals with
everybody.
I believe that's probably one promise he couldn't
make.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: As you mentioned, even though you've
left the Republican Party and you're anti-Trump,
you were one of the prominent voices in the
Tea Party movement back in 2010 ish.
And at the time, quite, quite a strong opponent
of then-President Barack Obama's.
In retrospect, Obama wasn't really too bad,
right?
Even even by your standards.
Speaker 5: I take it when I look back, sometimes
I want to slap myself upside the head.
Hmm.
Because you're right.
Obama.
Obama wasn't a crazy leftist in being in Congress
then, and that the talking points were always.
We had to call him a socialist and all of
the rest.
Yeah.
And I engaged in too much of that, but.
Oh, my God.
No, no, not at all.
And I've I've obviously over the years gained
much respect for Barack Obama, even if I still
genuinely disagree with him on most policy
issues.
Speaker 1: To talk about a policy issue, because
the last time we did this and it was interesting.
On taxes, right.
So top federal tax rate right now is 37%.
And there's the idea of maybe it would go
a little higher if Joe Biden got his way.
But we're talking about a couple of points
and then some say, well, we should have a
higher bracket that starts higher with an
even higher tax rate.
What do you think about the level of federal
taxation in the U.S. right now?
Like, what would if it was just up to you,
how would you organize tax brackets?
Speaker 5: If I were king of the world, David?
Yeah.
I'd get rid of our complicated tax code.
I might.
My.
My innate default is always to let every American
keep more of the money they make.
I'd.
I'd advocate and push some sort of flat tax,
one single rate for everybody.
I'd get low income people off of it, but everybody
else would pay the straight 25, 26% of what
you make and be done with all these complications
and all of these wealthy people who can hire
all these accountants and lawyers to end up
paying nothing.
Speaker 1: Well, so that's the critical question.
When people bring up a flat tax, which is,
okay, you deal with folks at the lower end
by saying it's actually zero up until a certain
point.
But then the first question becomes, is there
a single dollar number at which it goes from
0 to 26?
Because then that's the first thing people
would game, right, to try to stay right below
that because 0 to 26 is a big difference.
Speaker 5: So so one one way around that is
to just incrementally raise it to a certain
point.
Speaker 1: So it's no longer flat, is it.
Speaker 5: Then?
It's no longer flat, but it tops off at a
rate.
But I hear that concern and that's a concern
I've always had.
I'm not I'm less concerned about that than
the multitude of rates that create, the multitude
of complications that people like you and
I just can't take advantage of.
Speaker 1: So then the critical part really
is at the top because effective.
These billionaires aren't paying 26% right
now.
Speaker 5: So right now.
Speaker 1: If you do a flat tax that phases
in at the bottom from zero, that's.
So it's already kind of progressive.
Then what do you do at the top to prevent
getting deductions and carry a lot of interest
carryforwards and all these things?
How do you really make a billionaire pay 26%
effective?
Because for most of them, that's an increase
in what they pay.
Speaker 5: Well, so, so and again, we're talking
pie in the sky dreams.
Speaker 1: Of course.
Of course.
Speaker 5: Just remember, I'm king of the
world.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 5: If I put that number in there,
that flat rate of 26, 27, 28%.
Yep.
I would get rid of every deduction, every
exemption, everything on the books.
I'd remove all of it.
In my dream world.
Speaker 1: What about wages versus capital
gains?
That's another way, right?
Which is, well, sure, it's 26% flat, but I
can pay for much less depending on what it
is, by not taking a salary as many of these
guys don't.
What do you do about that?
Speaker 5: I I've always.
This is such great stuff, David.
Damn it.
And I miss this stuff.
Could do this.
I'd get rid of the capital gains tax.
Speaker 1: Just make it earn.
Same as income.
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah.
Don't.
Don't don't throw anything at me.
I'd probably.
I'd probably just.
Just count it as straight income, and I'd
get rid of the capital.
I'd get rid of every exception, and I would
count everything as income.
Speaker 1: What's crazy about this plan is
it's not very right wing, really.
I mean, like, as we talk through it, you're
basically saying tax capital gains is income,
which increases the amount rich people pay.
Take away the loopholes in the deductions,
which if you can get the very rich to pay
an effective rate of tax, they're actually
paying more.
And just make it progressive from zero up
to that 26 at the bottom.
It it's probably something a lot of left wingers
would get behind.
I mean, it doesn't sound bad to me.
Speaker 5: Would it in your mind, David, would
end up bringing in more revenue than what
we're bringing in now?
Speaker 1: I don't know, but it sounds like
it might.
Speaker 5: It might.
Yeah, it that's the weird.
Funny thing is, it actually might.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Policy folks we've been speaking
to here.
Speaker 5: By the way, David.
Neither political party is incentivized to
go down that road.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Former Republican Congressman Joe Walsh, you
can hear him on white flag with Joe Walsh.
Always great having you on.
Speaker 5: Keep doing your thing, David.
Thank you, man.